we had the craziest conversation with
tommy chong and and i asked him like
about
how much more
powerful marijuana has become
since like you know like the 70s or
whatever right and he shocked the [ __ ]
out of us saying it's not more powerful
it's the same plan it ever was like
well look i gotta disagree with my
mentor there
sorry tommy i gotta disagree with that
oh we were confused too we were like oh
i mean i can't i can agree
that
it's the same plant yeah but but the the
technology and and right the science the
like the understanding of how to like
make this a super plant has just
advanced it's like working out like for
a human being right
before
um in the 50s in the 50s athletes didn't
have supplements you just know your your
basic food groups that you should have
but there was no such thing as
supplements now there's trt now there's
just every [ __ ] supplement in the
world to maximize and make your workouts
efficient and work for you right still
the same person blood bone
dna all that [ __ ] but it'll knock you
out but we'll knock you the [ __ ] out
because
we're stronger
you don't want to put a 1950s nfl team
right they don't have a chance right as
great as they were back then they were
great with what they were dealing with
at the time right there's advancements
in everything right
so along with technology you know
there's advancements in nutrients for
the plants to
um promote
the different things that you need the
plant to do for it to be what you want
it to be right so
they didn't have
these things back in those days and most
of those dudes were growing outdoor yeah
you know and now there's these these
teas that you could use for for outdoor
cultivation where people were just you
know some some folks were just watering
their [ __ ] or home remedies
and stuff like that now you know not to
say that the dudes in the 60s and 70s
you know
some of them knew what the [ __ ] they
were doing like pro
but when you think about how many of
them there were it was a small number
most people were growing what we call
today boof
stress weed swag boo boo swag
you know what i mean [ __ ] that you were
[ __ ] yeah commerce [ __ ] you wouldn't
give to your enemy you know what i mean
um
that bad you know what i'm saying right
and so yes there were there's always
been talented growers in every
every
decade or every since its existence a
few small talented
groups in different cities different
states but these days there are more
talented cultivators why because
knowledge is out there the the you know
you can
you can find the way to do this [ __ ]
right if you got the money and you got
the right place and you got the setup
and it's clean and
you know you got the the the right
guidance you could per you could produce
awesome cannabis and there's more people
doing that today than there was back in
that day and right and the cannabis is
definitely stronger because because you
have these
the you know you have the technology and
you have these supplements for the
plants
to make them better
so last time the last time i bought weed
was over uh like in 2013 at on first in
alameda at the arts then there's some
dispensary right there and they're like
[ __ ] it just came out 13 flower thc and
everybody's getting high as [ __ ] now
it's like 33 percent
you're speaking in tongues after you
take a rip
like i couldn't handle that [ __ ] do you
have like
like a special like
like that like like where you're like
okay dude i don't even want to take on
the 33 but like like for a tip for this
morning like i gotta get some [ __ ] done
i'm gonna like yeah go for some weaker
[ __ ] yeah i mean i think every every
cannabis brand has its it's very you
know it's it's impactful [ __ ] and
the ones that you can function too you
know i mean we all have to have that
because if you want to sell to every
type of consumer or connoisseur
you got to have it
you know something that's like for the
the rookie the novice
something for the pro right you know and
not only that you have to have the right
blood tenders that have that knowledge
that can explain that to them are you a
first-time user are you in the middle or
are you
fully blown professional
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude